because daniel one of the things you're
not going to miss is the terrible toll
it is sacred on your body i don't know
i'm sitting here in the brace
no it's all great
no time to die no time to die what did
you break in no time to die my ankle
i mean you know
like literally walking down a plank i
mean not even i wasn't running wasn't
even doing anything action-based i just
walked down slipped and fell over it was
so stupid and over the films what so
what's the worst injury you've had
probably my knee which was on um spectre
which was um that was dave bautista god
bless him who is
a professional wrestler
we were doing this scene as a fight
sequence on um
a train in inspector
and we we learned this for weeks and
weeks and weeks and weeks and weeks and
and you know you kind of you basically
spend a week shooting it and the whole
thing is there and dave was being really
great with me but he's a big big guy and
i forget how big he is and he was sort
of throwing me against this wall he's
being gentle
because you know so he should it's
pretend
um
and i just said dave dave mate go on
it's all right come on you can chuck me
a bit don't worry about it i'm fine
so we did
i ended up on the wall but my knee was
sort of over here somewhere
and i said i went oh god like and it
went and i knew and it's horrible
because if anybody's had an injury they
kind of you know kind of that kind of
injury you just know in your head that
something's really wrong and
god bless him i i was out and then we
went back and we reformed it i had to
film it with a brace on and we kind of
and it was very it was a struggle to do
it but i got i broke his nose oh
what
um don't mess with the crate
i didn't do it literally clearly it was
like it was a mistake and it was so like
i mean like i said he's a big guy he's a
professional wrestler you really
wouldn't mess with him and i threw this
punch i hit him on the nose and i heard
this crack and i went oh god and ran
away
i thought he was gonna come up
and he was so sweet and he literally did
something like this he went away that's
fine no
i mean he's a lot tougher than i am i'll
give you that
[Music]
you